uh
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
all right jesus christ
we don't know what's up with this [ __ ] i
mean we kind of restarted it we'll see
give everybody a little bit has to come
in here let me see your your part on
your wig is very very quickly hey man
don't be [ __ ] don't be just you know
what i mean where does it go is it good
okay
ginger [ __ ] it with me i'm not [ __ ]
with you i'm just telling you all right
let me go ahead and get started
you were talking about ronnie james you
were talking about talking about metal
and [ __ ] all kinds of stuff well
like i said i kind of feel like the and
i think the reason that i wasn't into
metal maybe
was because
its whole shtick
not entirely true but particularly in
the 80s and maybe the early 90s its
whole shtick was
we're evil
and this is like [ __ ] your parents
wouldn't listen to so they were going
out of their way to be like [ __ ]
satanic uh no not all bands no i don't
know yeah i'm not saying everybody but i
do kind of feel like that was like kind
of like the angle they were trying to
come from on some of those bands sure on
some of those man and the problem was is
that once you went that route you
couldn't back off of it true if you
start talking about satan you got to
strictly deal with satan from then on
out you can't mix it with politics
you can't mix it with relationships well
you know
it [ __ ] up the credibility of your band
all the damn all the satanic metal bands
only dealt with satan
saying or maybe after a while
werewolves
werewolves and maybe some vampires that
was it that was it in witches
that's what they would deal with you
couldn't talk about your girlfriend
leaving you you know what i mean [ __ ]
man this shit's [ __ ] are we gonna
have to [ __ ] and she went red for a
second we're gonna have to [ __ ] end
the show what the [ __ ]
now we're all ready okay
all right
so
that was
dad's problem is that he got he got
caught a little bit in a time warp
and in the music industry it doesn't
take long
if you fall behind in 10 years you're
way out i mean you hem yourself in yeah
and he hemmed himself into this [ __ ]
satanic [ __ ] thing a bit and
once he started [ __ ] appearing where
he had to take his when he had his shirt
off and he's [ __ ] like yeah and he
wasn't that built uh he did a couple
cycles of things and
did some roids and and he wasn't all
that [ __ ] stacked
and this you can't come off of that you
got to stay that way
you know what i mean if you're going to
do that in public you got to stay that
way
and because that's not what happened he
[ __ ]
came off cycle didn't do pct properly
gained a bunch of weight and also he's
an older fat guy buying cat litter
buying cat litter
well he didn't look that bad during the
cat litter phase he got fatter [ __ ]
i mean he gave him [ __ ] look we
everybody has to buy cat litter come on
the cat are taking care of you what it
is is that once you've puffed yourself
up into the [ __ ] dark lord of the
[ __ ] underworld and [ __ ] you can't be
seen [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
buying kitty litter you're really kind
of like shooting yourself in the dirt
because honestly everybody has to if you
are a loving
cat
uh parent as we are
uh yeah you gotta buy cat litter you
gotta poop so this could have all been
mitigated
had he [ __ ] uh been real jovial and
charismatic during his exactly and
that's why i'm saying he's on the steven
seagal spectrum
of
taking his stupid ass to syria yeah
you can't be dark lord of the [ __ ]
whatever all the time and then you have
to do normal real person [ __ ] like
buying cat litter or toilet paper for
example because somebody takes a picture
of you nowadays doing that which
somebody will because it's the 21st
century
uh that's gonna go all over the internet
and people are gonna be like oh look the
dark lord of whatever and he's buying
[ __ ] toilet paper so
you know just be a regular person you
should uh what he should have done is
during um his interviews and i
understand the media was not quite as it
was a lot more restricted back in the
day he started doing it i mean getting
air time was [ __ ]
really hard
he should have been [ __ ]
funny
and [ __ ] friendly
and yeah and and that would have [ __ ]
and
endeared people to him a lot more
because you take yourself too seriously
everyone's gonna like [ __ ] uh relish
in taking your stupid ass uh he came
from a narrow band society
yeah the times were different back then
and he's appearing
in it only a decade or so before drastic
changes of the internet
so he nobody had considered that
so he didn't quite make the transition
um
too bad though
it's well
nowadays it's hard to maintain
uh an image that is not predicated upon
reality in any sense i kind of feel like
it's much easier
for people like us who are just like
acting like our regular ass
dumbass selves
in public and we don't have any like
image to maintain other than we're just
our dumb ass selves yeah uh if you have
some kind of like i'm the satanic dark
lord of whatever and it's like
like all that uh somebody takes a
picture of you buying cat litter then
yeah that's going to be a problem
whereas if somebody knocked the [ __ ] out
if somebody well that too if somebody
took a picture of me buying cat litter
and just be like yeah i'm buying cat
litter because cat's got a poop yeah
and we have would have played out
differently had he just kind of been
himself but maybe sure maybe that wasn't
himself or maybe he is a dick i i don't
know
um
i honestly might have been a little
stuffy about himself i don't know i
think that's
that's his major issue and like i said
he's not as bad as steven seagal but we
bring up steven seagal is kind of like
he's like at the far end of the spectrum
yeah
when you get to a point where you can't
laugh at yourself and you can't you're
you're like not even like a human
anymore you're always kind of like well
i can't be seen doing this and the other
thing
and
people can't make jokes about you
and you like take everything way too
seriously
then
yeah people are going to uh relish
taking you down because
it's easy that being said
that being said steven seagal
is a fake okay
in in most at most respects well
everybody knows glenn danzig wasn't
glenn danson can sing he can write he is
yeah he can see that dude live and
[ __ ] he was awesome back when hit
back in his heyday back in the 90s up in
boston in the [ __ ] like 94 or 95
around that time
and uh no he was [ __ ] awesome live
[ __ ] great show
and uh no he was [ __ ] punching way
above his [ __ ] weight um
he's really good really good
it's just he made some [ __ ] public
image mistakes you know i mean like but
he didn't know what was going on and i
think at the time as i said taking
yourself too seriously is always a big
mistake please don't ever do that if
you're uh in the public eye i mean
honestly the best thing that you can do
is just play it off yeah just be a
person yeah everybody else is a person
they will get it
it's fine
but uh you know [ __ ] if uh [ __ ]
no if anybody's never heard him or
[ __ ] don't know who we're talking
about no [ __ ] clandestine was the
[ __ ] [ __ ] he he's good he's real good
yeah um
like i said at least he has some talent
i'm like he's good some other people
that i just like yeah yeah steven scott
didn't have any talent really not really
no
i mean
i mean you must have some talent because
he kind of got famous yeah but
there's other people i can think of that
are more talented in uh areas that he
was supposedly talented in
that didn't really get a chance because
of him
i don't know there's a lot of things
that go into talent it's not always
talent
yeah i remember one thing that stephen
king said this actually
uh and i think it was in
might have been in dance macabre or
might have been in on writing and he
said
talent is as cheap as table salt
uh basically a lot of people are
talented yeah it's all in what you just
look at us do with it
yeah
all in what you do with it how you
market yourself so it's always kind of
like and honestly like i've heard about
a lot of stories like [ __ ] writers
and stuff like that i mean i'm really
into horror directors and horror writers
and stuff
people that made one [ __ ] brilliant
ass movie or may or wrote like a couple
brilliant ass books
and
they weren't really recognized sometimes
they were recognized like after they
died yeah which
is kind of sad but it
it was just it wasn't necessarily any
fault of their own um they wrote some
brilliant ass [ __ ] but either the world
was not ready for it or
they didn't know how to market it or
whoever marketed it and didn't know how
to market it so there are a lot of other
factors at play
so
being talented at something
doesn't always mean something and i know
that's like that's really like shitty to
think about but
there's a lot of other factors that are
kind of out of your control
that
have to do with like how successful you
are at something so what you have being
at the right place at the right time and
then knowing learning how to [ __ ]
market that and exploit that
and then how to endear other people to
you charisma has a lot to do with it
and uh
the only problem
a guy like glenn danzig had was he had a
charisma problem he didn't know how he
did i think that was his main issue
honestly that might have been his only
issue yeah he'd agree but it's kind of a
big deal right and it's kind of and not
about his looks he looked good yeah um
it was just uh he didn't know
how to charm people
and
keep
people on his side
and and to recruit
he couldn't recruit
not not through charm he recruited
through music he was just all music and
singing and
he was good though real good i mean he's
[ __ ] great
um even some of his later stuff that i'd
never heard before i went back and
looked at that you know i mean and it
was like oh yeah i mean so he was he was
always strong
and um
uh [ __ ] [ __ ] he made friends with um
uh
[ __ ] who was the western singer [ __ ]
who did uh
uh folsom prison bruce jenny johnny cash
yeah he became friends with johnny cash
they did so
the glenn wrote songs for johnny cash
so you know yeah cash cash johnny cash
he was a charismatic dude covered yeah
nick caves the mercy seat yeah that was
the thing about [ __ ] and that was a
fit it was a completely different than
the caves version but it was also
brilliant that was one of the strong
parts of [ __ ] cash i don't consider
cash a country singer i see just
consider him a western singer johnny
cash
to me he's kind of like one of those
figures that just likes
spreads like all genres so he knew how
to charm people and go into other venues
so you had guys in the metal scene
listening to [ __ ] johnny cash sure
you know he was good
i mean he was doing nine inch nails
[ __ ] wasn't he [ __ ] wasn't trump
yeah yeah like i said he covered in a
cave he covered nine inch nails and it
wasn't
he's so cool yeah that nobody said
okay old man what are you doing like
covering like these cool like yeah
like nobody said that no they're like oh
okay because johnny cash
treatment was one of those people that
just transcended
genre transcended era and generations uh
which is very rare you don't really see
that a lot but johnny cash was
absolutely david bowie was another one
um was one of those people that just
absolutely yeah
out of time yeah uh so
it didn't really matter like what area
you were from what genre you were from
uh he could do it and it was it was fine
no one was gonna complain cash did a
cover of a nine inch nail song called
hurt that [ __ ] was [ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah
and like i said he covered uh nick
cave's the mercy seat yeah and he did
it's really interesting because the
nikkei version is very
i don't even know what genre i'd call it
it's kind of it's a very post punk like
kind of version uh
johnny cash did a more
i don't want to say it's like
necessarily acoustic but he did a more
acoustic version of it and it's also
brilliant he did like a completely
different thing with it but
it really it really worked in the
context
um so
you know
if you have that and like i said it's
very rare that doesn't really happen a
lot because i do kind of feel like
sometimes
if somebody like glenn danzig attempted
that i think everybody would be like no
you know what i mean
there's only a very very small
percentage of people
that could
that just transcend
genre and era in that way
and i can't i can only really think of
maybe a handful of people
that you could do that and it would be
fine and no one would complain about it
because it was like oh of course that
works
but
most of the time everyone's just kind of
like no what are you doing stop it
so i kind of feel like
as cool as glenn danzig is
uh or was i guess back in the day no
he's cool it's easy
but he's not johnny cash cool he's not
david bowie cool no no
you know what i mean that's that's a
whole other
and i can't even explain what it is
that's a whole other level and it's like
that's not even like that's several
levels above
humans yeah
generally
so
and it's not so much a [ __ ] on
how they die
[Laughter]
on how they die and uh
[ __ ] david bowie died he died strong
and the [ __ ] looked good it was
making the music video dying of cancer
putting out his last album and he put
the [ __ ] out you're like what the [ __ ]
did that mean then you find out later oh
by the way i'm dead
[ __ ] you know there you go that was
your last album david bowie's whole
entire life to me that is like
an instructional manual because he was
just like
everything he did was just like it was
perfect perfect and then um david's last
[ __ ] word his last message to us as
mortals okay tell he told this to me to
ahmad
[ __ ] he goes tell them i was always a
closeted heterosexual
which to me
that's like the cherry on top
did he really say that i don't know yeah
even if he did it according to him
according to iman that's what he said
tell him i was always a closeted
heterosexual
which that isis which might have been he
was dying he's like look this is not
really my last words but tell everybody
this yeah yeah he's [ __ ]
but like i said yeah and if that was
true then like he was thinking about the
[ __ ] to the end and i was just like
because even before
before he died there were people who who
knew him and [ __ ] his band members
[ __ ] you know what i mean look at
like what is his name mars i think his
name was [ __ ] mick mars
they had they were going to all these
gay clubs dressed up in the gay clothes
back in the 70s and they were very
uncomfortable because these are british
working-class guys and they're straight
and uh what [ __ ] bowie's one of his
strengths was is that he could feel the
market and see what was coming
and he had
one of his major advantages that he knew
how
to recruit sponsorship from powerful
gay men in the [ __ ] art scenes and in
the music scenes to help them fund these
projects and he would make profit
and um
he knew how to put on a good act and you
had rich gay guys who wanted to see that
act brought to the mainstream
and
he knew how to [ __ ] raise money the
thing about bowie though and like i said
i don't think you could do this um
it wasn't like fake that's what i'm
saying i i don't multimedia i don't
think you could do this like calculate
in a calculated way no i think the
reason that bowie worked was because i
don't think he was overthinking it to
anybody he was thinking about it sure
but i don't think he was overthinking it
to a point where i'm going to do this
because this will make me x amount of
dollars oh no
he wanted to see happen yeah and he just
happened to
have the right enthusiasm have the right
personality know the right people
to get that stuff happen at that
particular time yeah uh if it was a
different time it might not have worked
the same way
if it was you know it was just like the
right place right time again right guy
yeah at for the time and another thing
is is that we you know david bowie as a
musician
and that's not really how he saw himself
he wanted to be an actor
so he's doing multimedia stuff he's
using
music as kind of like his
as a venue for him to show you
characters he's created every one of
those albums back in the 70s he's being
a different character yeah that was kind
of his whole thing and he was in movies
as well man he was in the hunger he was
in labyrinth he was in the linguine
incident right have you guys seen that
because
i was kind of obsessed with that movie
like back in the [ __ ] ladies
some of his characters were kind of
gender bending and some of her and then
he's playing kind of [ __ ] characters
that have [ __ ] neuroses neuroses and
stuff you know
he's playing characters that have drug
problems like the thin white duke you
know or he's a coke freak you know what
i mean or he's probably well you know or
an alien or a guy or a rock star or a
kid from england who's
got a rock band pretending to be an
alien or a vampire or a vampire or this
you know yeah that's it watch the hunger
exactly when i was talking about on the
album it's not so much the movies yeah
uh the albums were were a vehicle for uh
bowie to put on a show and to act he
always considered himself an entertainer
not a not a not well as i said and we
talked about this a little bit on our
vamp review
which i put up earlier uh grace jones
kind of had the same thing where uh you
know your whole life is kind of like
performance art so whatever media
is available to you at the time you want
to be like you know cross genre
multimedia and i kind of feel like grace
jones was doing that david bowie's doing
that whether it was like music or movies
or art or whatever the [ __ ] you were
doing
because honestly like creative people
you see possibility in all different
kinds of media
and you don't really want to be
restricted by one particular media i
don't want to just be a painter i don't
want to just be a movie maker i want to
do all these other things
you know yeah which i kind of feel like
i have that problem too because
there's so many possibilities it's just
kind of like man i could like write
books i could do like [ __ ]
i could design a video game i could do
this on the other like and especially
nowadays because there's so many
different like possibilities and it's
almost like the hardest part is like
winnowing yourself down to like one
thing it was that they showed up did we
lose connection no it's just that's just
a email
notification
i get email notifications so that's what
that is
uh let's see they're talking about food
which
yeah cheryl says johnny cash's hurt is
beautiful it is honestly
i'm going to say i think i like the
johnny cash version more than the
nightish nails version
a little bit
because i love i mean i love johnny cash
anyway like i liked all his old [ __ ] but
when he started like covering
you know sort of goth people like in the
90s and stuff i was kind of like oh it's
on my mind well there was an
intersection going on at that time well
yeah and honestly like uh he got kind of
a resurgence i feel like in the 90s
because he put out uh what's that song
dealie is gone
do you remember that i have them on my
phone
and it was like an old school country
song but it was like a you know like a
lot of them were like a murder song
and it's a great and i think that was
only like a year or two after nick cave
put out like for example like murder
ballads so there was kind of like a
sort of like a resurgence of that type
of stuff
and he put that out and they played the
video on mtb they played it on 120
minutes like on their alternative show
and it's a [ __ ] great ass song we're
talking about bowie's uh
house
some of his houses with iman
the last i had heard
that my information is pretty old though
um
david bowie was
the most wealthy
musician
okay
even more so than say michael jackson
but he had not made that money through
music he made it through real estate
invest investment and art dealing
and we kind of know in the modern world
that art dealing has a lot to do with
[ __ ]
money laundering okay but that's just a
sign of his intelligence you know what i
mean [ __ ]
so
bowie understood the scam too
but he had a lot of
he would
uh his name and his power
gave him enough credit line to buy some
[ __ ]
very [ __ ] important properties
throughout the world [ __ ]
[ __ ] mansions on the island of borneo
[ __ ] all kinds of stuff up in
indonesia you know
he had a bunch of uh great properties
and then he had a lot of friends
in the old me the old dinosaur media
like [ __ ] um
uh uh [ __ ] the humming gardens
magazines
and they would do whole [ __ ]
layouts on some
house that he owned
why because he's going to sell it and
give him the kickback you know i mean
it's just
that was the old way of doing [ __ ] but
they still do that nowadays they still
do that yeah
but you know if you buy a house
and you go yeah this is david bowie's
old [ __ ]
house on the island of borneo you know
what i mean [ __ ] you you're [ __ ]
the man you know you got [ __ ] one of
bowie's houses you know hitting
[ __ ] probably he's only there a
couple times but it doesn't matter you
know well it's historic because yeah
which one of these rooms were hit where
bowie and imani [ __ ] your mom [ __ ] in
yeah it was like let's imagine what's
going on what kind of parties did they
have the bedroom into that room yeah
we're gonna get we're gonna get some
bowie iman energy yeah all right
let me go get you another
uh cheryl says bowie was so sexy i agree
honestly um
can i just say i love
that somebody as weird
as bowie
became
essentially a worldwide icon
to a to a point where
i mean he was so [ __ ] influential on
so many i mean particularly music but a
lot of other media as well
and it's just kind of like i love that i
love somebody as like weird as that
was so [ __ ] influential and so iconic
uh tila says jen i know you love the
hunger i do which i did bad for bowie's
character in that one i did too honestly
i don't know if you ever read the book
which was written by whitley strieber
the same guy that wrote communion uh
where he
apparently um
legitimately claimed that he was
kidnapped by aliens which okay whitley
streamer
uh the hunger it was a pretty good book
but
i will say and it i did like that it
went more into miriam's
backstory like in ancient egypt and
stuff but this is one of the very rare
cases thank you
where i thought the movie was much
better
i know a lot of people complained about
the movie it's tony scott by the way um
being more uh style over substance was i
think was the most uh prolific
uh criticism
looks like a music video but honestly
that was one of the things i liked about
it and i to be honest yeah it does kind
of it looks awesome i just love the
whole like visual of it
but the reason i love the hunger is
because the implication
of the vampire myth in that one
is so much more horrific
than
uh the actual like a lot of vampire
movies
to be honest with you seeing vampire
movies i'm like oh you get bit by a
vampire and the like oh you live forever
and you can just like do it i'm like
that sounds kind of awesome
um the hunger
went into a little bit more of a
scientific direction in the sense that
miriam who was kind of the head vampire
she was thousands of years old they
implied that she came from ancient egypt
or whatever and her whole thing
it was a very tragic movie because she
was trying to
find
uh an eternal love somebody that would
like stay with her forever
so she kept turning
um companions that she felt an affinity
for
but after two or three hundred years uh
you know the vampire blood the human
blood it wasn't compatible so it would
start to break down after a while and
they would start to age very very
rapidly but the kicker of it was they
would age very rapidly but they wouldn't
die
and the [ __ ] up thing was that miriam
couldn't bear
to kill them
so she would keep them so she kept
these
people that had been her
companions for hundreds of years she
would just put them in a box and stick
them up in the attic because she
couldn't
deal with like killing them but they
were still alive and they were rotting
uh because like i said the the blood
wasn't compatible so to me
that whole like concept
was way more like horrific than any
other like vampire thing and it was just
like a bonus that the movie itself
looked
fabulous like i loved the inside of
their apartment and like all the blowing
curtains and all the bird like the doves
and [ __ ] like that flying and obviously
bauhaus was in it that was [ __ ]
fantastic bowie was in it fantastic it
was just like a great [ __ ] movie i
love that movie so much i've seen it a
million million [ __ ] times
if you've never seen the hunger from
1983 if you're into vampire movies
you've been to 80s movies and you want
to see some like real like i said it's
it's very stylish
but the implications of it way more
horrific than any other vampire movie
because it's not just a case of oh we'll
bite you and you're a vampire and you're
you live forever and you're beautiful um
yeah not not quite it's a little more
complicated than that and honestly
to me that was like a lot
worse
so i liked it more
uh cheryl says the hunger is so
beautiful how hot was susan sarandon oh
and another thing too if you uh ever
wanted to see a movie in which a very
young susan sarandon and a very young
catherine denove
have sex with one another
the hunger that's your movie
that's your movie oh you put on your joe
dirtwig
ah what's up pokey fans hi pookie what's
up
what are you doing
let's see um
um
jason says
[Music]
i got so behind
we were talking about the hunger and i
got like all distracted
got all distracted
no need for me too says i saw that bowie
movie man who fell to earth
weird for a young kid to see yeah i saw
that when i was a younger kid too and
like yeah
we just watched it recently like a few
months ago because we reviewed it
that is a very weird movie i can't
believe i saw that when i was like a
teenager oh you brought pool camp yeah
oh hi sweetie
it's a good movie
they kind of [ __ ] some things up about
that movie yeah but yeah i think it was
budgetary there's a lot of the problems
there's some stuff there are some scenes
that should have been in there
that weren't
tommy's the same do you think i would uh
do it no i'm not gonna [ __ ] sing this
one
cheryl says bowie lived rather uh
modestly considering his wealth
yeah i mean
he always seemed
i don't know he just always seemed like
not down to earth necessarily i'm not
even sure there's a word for it
well look um he seemed like genuine but
also like weird at the same time
if you ever like watch any videos
on youtube you know about [ __ ] um
abandoned mansions and [ __ ] stuff
like that
you'll see in the comment section
sometimes people who are in the real
estate business making comments
about the mansion gig
a lot of people that buy those mansions
eventually don't like them
especially if it's too big they end up
living in just a few rooms kind of like
we do here
the the human wasn't really
meant to be in a big sprawling
it's like you're in a hotel
so they end up kind of cloistering
themselves into a couple couple rooms
that's that's more what what the human's
all about
so
people that have a whole [ __ ] ton of
money buy those things mostly for the
neighborhood and the clout
all right well because it makes them
look rush
you know i might have parties in them
for a while but
when you have a real mansion you have to
run the thing like a damn business
yeah because who's having that many
parties that you need that much room i
mean you need a whole staff to like to
just to keep the [ __ ] clean you need a
whole staff keep the [ __ ] clean you need
a maintenance staff to come make sure
everything's [ __ ] looking good
nothing's together just a few weeks
everything just goes to [ __ ] hell
it's big it's like running a business
yeah
so um
i really see it that you know a guy like
bowie or a lot of other guys you know
after a couple maybe a decade or so
[ __ ] the mansion game they're [ __ ]
sick of that they just have them
to
for for the for the status and to live
in certain neighborhoods the rest of
them are just investments they probably
buy and sell them to make more money
then they probably get sick of making
money because
some guys will make so much money it'll
just sit up in the back go yeah i'm good
i can i can sit back and live on that
that'd be nice if i if i had that yeah
and then yeah i forgot how much money
yeah like
i
whatever
20 million that's good
and then um i won't starve i guess right
now
that'll pay for this place for 30 years
and i won't live that long so yeah right
and then um so that's probably what
happens with guys like bowie is that
they
make a [ __ ] ton of money and then
eventually get sick of that get sick of
it and then they end up living in a
couple rooms in some mansion somewhere
and the rest of the mansion's mostly
disused like a hotel
um
the mansion game around here you can
order one out of the catalog fully
furnished they'll build that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] record time you show up it's
already got furniture in it and
everything
and they'll even arrange it for you and
put paintings and artwork up and
there's your instant mcmansion
you know
and uh you probably feel like you're in
a hotel like it's not really so much
your house
but they
uh they'll live in them for a while and
then dudes will go bankrupt and then
they'll sit there for 10 15 years
falling apart and then they're
eventually demolished because you can't
sell a mansion there's not enough buyers
well and like i said anybody that has
enough money to buy and customize a
mansion they want they're gonna have it
to their tastes yep and their tastes are
not necessarily going to align with most
people's tastes as most people stay
still
i'm sure if i built a mansion to my
specifications
nobody would want that [ __ ] i guarantee
it right now but i would have a good
time at it anybody who can afford a four
three four or five million dollar
mansion they're not gonna buy a used
mansion they're gonna buy a brand new
mansion
yeah that's what i mean if you have
enough money yeah to buy that then you
have enough money to have one
customized for you yep
so why would you want somebody else's
like sloppy seconds yep because it's not
like back in the old days where they set
it down damn foundation and they're
[ __ ] using stones and [ __ ]
mortar work and brick work no it's
[ __ ] they'll build that [ __ ] in
about a month
a couple weeks and it's made out of the
same kind of material that you have here
it's just
cheap ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] fiberboard and [ __ ]
sheetrock and
same kind of appliances the same kind of
[ __ ] fixtures it's not even really
that big of a deal they're just bigger
and lots of glass and a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ] air conditioning units to keep
the thing cool
you know you're probably spending
[ __ ] two three thousand dollars a
month just in [ __ ] electric electric
and cooling bills eating and cooling
cheryl says iman did a tour of one of
their houses on youtube recently
i cried like a baby felt so much like
bowie's space yeah to be honest with you
i'm not like real big into like when
celebrities die i'm just uh kind of like
okay whatever yeah that sucks
when bowie died
that was a whole other thing
we were at
eye bar yeah um
after bowie died
yeah they played bowie like
not all night but they played like a lot
of bowie songs like over the night and i
was okay most of the time
and then they played
changes
and i was out dancing and i just started
crying
and i was like oh my god it's so
embarrassing it was and honestly like
the next day at work i was at work the
next day
and i saw something on youtube about
like somebody like and then i just
started crying again at work
so that was like the only time that that
happened like with a quote unquote
celebrity dying was when bowie because
honestly [ __ ] man
my whole entire [ __ ] existence i kind
of feel like bowie
one he made being a weirdo okay
i kind of feel like he was instrumental
in that
and he was also very influential in most
of the
music genres that i enjoy nowadays we'll
see you around tila tina's about leaving
bye-bye oh okay bye yeah
so
him dying i mean i knew it was going to
happen because he was getting old and
stuff but that was like a really big
blow
and i thought that it wouldn't affect me
that much but it really really did it
was yeah it really got to me
uh let's see
yeah ian says bowie was authentic that's
not a common thing to say yeah that's
the thing it's like he was
it's weird because he had like his whole
thing was like artifice but you felt
like it wasn't artifice like he was
genuinely
that weird
but
you don't really see that a lot like i
said you see people that are like quote
unquote weird and a lot of times it
comes across as tryhard like we were
saying before but he absolutely didn't
that was absolutely what he was like
and
you know and it and it worked
uh you don't really see that it's it's a
very very uh hard line to like walk i
guess
yeah people are saying 17 people
watching what the hell happened well we
we uh got dropped off
we had to restart because
and we've been streaming for a long time
it's actually time to
probably end the show and i'll make it
something to eat actually well wait a
minute let me uh answer some questions
go ahead and answer some [ __ ]
uh first contact with bowie was uh
labyrinth says
i was hooked the dude was so [ __ ]
good
i mean
i was into him before that but
labyrinth i think was
a lot of people's introduction
particularly people my age and
man he was so [ __ ] great in that and
honestly i just watched labyrinth again
i saw it a million times when i was kid
but i i just recently watched it again
we have a criterion don't we wear a
blu-ray yeah i got a really good version
of that yeah
yeah it's good i mean
god damn it and like i said i'm yeah i
mean
everything about that is fantastic
jennifer connolly is great in it she's
great in everything music the the music
is great in it the you know like all the
symbolism the champions and [ __ ] is the
you know any any jim henson thing i'm
it's a
female coming of age story how to choose
a man how to choose a man the problems
of women what women you know women well
women and men problems is what it's all
about it's her
uh
coming to womanhood yeah
she starts out as being like this very
you know cranky moody i don't want to
you know take care of this baby i don't
want to like take any responsibility i
don't so it's like a girl like growing
up to adulthood she like finds her
adulthood but
i like that they still have the thing
where at the end
uh she comes back to her room and all
the little monsters and stuff are still
there and they're like look if you need
us we're still here so it's like she's
not
you know completely abandoning her
childhood
in the sense of you know fantasy fun
stuff like that
it's still there for her
but she's taking responsibility now so
it's like a a girl's coming of age story
like you're taking responsibility but
you can still have fun you can still
like do this stuff from you know your
old days
um
yeah we talked about like the hunger
honestly that's
easily one of my favorite movies of the
80s i could watch it over and over and
over again i never get tired of that
[ __ ] movie
um
caitlyn higgins says do you know why
they're rich or so weird because they
can afford to be
true
that's bad man
yeah he says batman i say he died i mean
they can get away with a lot more like
you know
if us uh plebes
did some [ __ ] like they did
like rich people did yeah everybody
would like think it was weird but
not so much when they do it
um let me see where was i
celeb deaths don't hit me but artist
deaths do yeah i think that's kind of
why honestly i think
okay i was upset
honestly after david bowie dying i think
that was kind of like the thing that
affected me the most even though i
didn't ex i didn't expect it to
it
it hit me harder than i thought it would
um but the second most
of that
ilk that hit me was marky smith
uh if you guys don't know
uh i'm really into the fall i don't know
how popular they're in the us probably
not all that much but you know they're a
british band they're from manchester
and i'm really really into the fall
and i didn't actually know and this is
what shitty marquee smith died
and
hardly anybody covered it i only found
out about it because my sister
sent me an article from nme i think it
was new musical express from uh uk if
you don't know
and that told me that he died
and i was kind of like [ __ ] me i was
like i never got to see them live and i
love that [ __ ] band
and that kind of hit me hard too not as
hard as bowie but almost
uh and i think it hit me harder because
nobody else really cared about it but me
i don't know
am i the only person in the u.s that's
into the fall i don't know i guess
i guess
uh but yeah and i never got to see them
live and now i can't because he's dead
now
okay i don't know about you but i'm
starving i'm gonna look at him i am also
that i have to
uh
answer
did you do
okay yeah tls has got to take off now
for the fam okay so
i guess we're doing okay yeah
all right so there's not any questions
that we haven't answered
okay no need for me says i feel you
jenny
yeah that's you know oh when we're
starting to go red okay
all right so i guess we're going to like
wrap it up we've been going for a while
now yeah we'll see you guys [ __ ]
food sunday sunday
sunday we are going to talk about do you
want to talk about the black cat yeah we
can talk about it we're going to talk
we're going to go back to the [ __ ]
1930s man yeah boris carlisle
black cat check it out we watched the
black cat on shutter so we're going to
talk about that uh on sunday afternoon
so be sure to come by for that so thanks
for hanging out with us for this friday
night have a good
weekend up until then
and thanks for all your super chats we
will see you on sunday afternoon
bye